we want to show up at our best on a
health front on the wealth run
and relationship from that's our path to
deepest fulfillment you can be your best
and still be peaceful you can be your
best
and still be calm you can be your best
and still not be stressed
just focus on being the light because
eventually
you know light wins at the end of the
day we all know that star wars right
and here we are hey evan
mr partaker how you doing man yeah i'm
good man
i'm good end of the week you know it's 7
p.m
here in london so ready to rock and roll
into the weekend how about you
i love it uh it's 2pm here so i'm still
i still got i still got a lot more to do
still got a lot of
a lot of i think this is actually uh
a big point of discussion for a lot of
if you want to be a high achieving
entrepreneur it's like two o'clock on a
friday
it's winter coved
you know it's like you know just do
whatever right i mean that's what a lot
of people that kind of just start to
check out about now where it's like no i
got i'm on a mission
i got stuff to do we've got lives of
change like this is important
right right i think that makes a big
difference for a lot of entrepreneurs
i would totally but you know and and you
can't deny the feeling right it's like
everyone gets that feeling they don't
want to do stuff but
one of one of my fav i love this way
of of thinking so it's uh and this is
credit to
steven pressfield who made me think in
this way but the
the definition of a professional versus
an amateur
right so an amateur needs to feel like
doing something
right in order to do it whereas a
professional takes action whether they
feel like it or not or
said in another way like you know an
amateur needs feeling to precede action
whereas a professional flips the script
and they're like no no it's action that
generates feeling
and there's so many i mean the amount of
times like i wake up
in the day and it's like i look at my
schedule and it's 100 oh my god i want
to do
absolutely everything on my list that
honestly that that doesn't you know but
what separates those who
succeed from the rest is that they show
up as a pro and on those moments when
they don't feel like doing it they're
like uh whatever
let me just start for five minutes
action will generate the feeling and
they get at it anyway
i love it i think of it every day as a
battle between
growth you and comfort you yes
exactly it's not like you know eric
me tony robbins brendon burchard you
don't wake up he's like
yeah i'm ready for the day right it's
like
you want a bed and you want to stand
with the blankets and you want to take
friday afternoons off and you then
that's comfort you talking
but but growth you wants to go change
the world and requires you to get up and
do something
um anyway so i didn't even introduce
eric we just
started jamming eric super successful
entrepreneur
out of the uk that i met at brendan
burchard's
uh event in puerto rico he's the author
of the new book
the three alarms i got in here um this
is i got i got the special
i got hold on hold on i got the special
signed copy guys with the
super nice description but you can get
your copy
where's the best piece to go people want
the three alarms where are they going
well as a thank you for people are tuned
in right now just head over to um my
instagram there's a link in my bio and i
i'll actually hook you up with a free
digital copy so
follow the link to my bio and you get a
free digital copy of the book it
it's a it's hit best seller status on
amazon so you can if you want get it
from amazon i won't complain
but uh yeah you could definitely get a
free digital copy just follow the link
in my bio
how long is that how long is that going
to last because this is on youtube too
so
youtube will link that up in the
description below but how long is that
going
eric we'll keep it up long enough so
that it applies for a month after
youtube
okay all right cool so what i love about
the book you're talking about being
um the healthiest you the wealthiest you
and then the most loving you which was
which is a cool
take as well because people usually it's
like health wealth
and happiness but i like how you put it
to
the most loving you um
just talk talk us through you know what
are the three alarms
and why is why did you write the book
why is it so important
yeah it's so so it's really a book about
flipping the script
like realizing that um you kind of have
to think
counter-intuitively about a lot of
things uh and or bring a lot of
intentionality into things so
real quick so i'm gonna tell us the
story we're gonna go back 10 years
um i'm boarding a plane return flight to
london
i've been working my ass off for a
decade prior to that and um
and i thought i was invincible you know
i was like i could just do whatever i
want
and uh cabin doors closing the plane
plane's ascending
i start to feel something's up
something's not right
i get a lot of pressure building in my
chest seeing the pressure becomes
pain boom it's shooting down my left
shoulder into my left arm
i got my buddy sat next to me and i'm
like louis dude
check out my arm because this is this is
not right lewis feels my left arm
actually i was just on the phone with
louis just before this this is crazy
and um and lewis is like man your arm
feels like it's been hanging in a meat
locker
and that's what i felt too it's like
completely ice cold louis runs the
stewardess to get some help
she rushes over takes my vital sigh i'm
sorry i asked there's a doctor on board
doctor rushes over takes my vital signs
and then
i hear we need to land the plane
immediately i think he's having a heart
attack
and when you hear that 35 000 feet up in
the air
that's like my heart right now like i
feel my heart in my chest right now
it feels uncomfortable i i get i get
like agitated again
even just talking about it you know and
um
so that was attorney so uh obviously i
survived this would be like the most
amazing trick in the book if i hadn't
um but so plain lands emerge emergency
lands uh
emergency response seeing boards a plane
takes me off uh
you know into an ambulance waiting on
the runway they administer some nitrates
open up the arteries increase blood flow
to the heart
and as the ambulance speeds off to the
local hospital
you know i looked up into the eyes of
the french paramedic looking down at me
we were flying over france
time and um and i said please don't let
me die i have a five-year-old son
who's 15 now and
the the next day you know that was a
turning point for me because the next
day i woke up in the hospital
and uh and i thought what the hell am i
doing with my life you know i i had been
working
100 hour weeks as a consultant uh helped
build up skype before we sold it to ebay
and it was just like work work work you
know building some of my own my own
companies
and it just struck me that is something
interesting about that i thought so
work got me into that situation or my
approach to works obviously work is
important to me even though my approach
to it was wrong
my health was ready to fail so obviously
health is important yet the first words
out of my mouth in the ambulance it
wasn't like
you know please don't let me die um i
got to clear out my inbox
right please don't let me i have a
five-year-old son so relationship
so i you know i wanted to continue
performing
at my best but i realized that i had to
do it across that three-legged stool you
know
health wealth and relationships and then
that eventually
led to that this idea the three alarms
really simple i have three alarms that
go off in my phone
for like years now and the idea is that
we want to we want to show up at our
best on a health front on the wealth run
and when i say wealth i mean both making
the money and invest in it wealth front
and relationship front
that's our path to deepest fulfillment
show up at your best the superhero
version of you across all those three
domains
and i segmented my day into three parts
you know here's generally the health
segment well segment relationship
segment i pick the best self like
superhero version
of me in each of those segments and then
i just put it as an alarm on my phone
so at 6 30 am on my phone
alarm goes off and it says world fitness
champion
because that's the version of me that
goes to the gym in the morning it's like
i go into the phone booth i change the
whirlpool fitness champion boom
i go to the i go i go to the go to the
gym um
9 a.m next one goes off it says world's
best coach i mean that's what i do these
days i you know coach entrepreneurs
leaders and it just reminds me well how
does that version of me show up
and then the game changer one for me at
6 30 p.m
it goes off um and it says world's best
husband and father just to prompt the
question
how would the world's best husband and
father walk through that door right now
so the three alarms is really about
helping you bring
intentionality and giving you some tools
so that you show up on your best
at your best on the health front wealth
front and home front
if you guys don't know eric yet you're
gonna love him because he's he's got
this
weird analytical
mind that can just like make systems and
structure
out of concepts so like everybody talks
about how important health and wealth
and
all this stuff is but eric can actually
turn it into
practical uh actionable
uh takeaways which is why i love talking
to him and you guys are gonna love the
three alarms
um so what does that mean so like when
you go and then
let's say your your 6 30 alarm goes off
i'm going to be the world's greatest
husband and father what is that is it
just the
that'll that alarm alone prompts you to
think do you have something
scheduled that you would do is it like
what happened 6 30 goes up
you're in the middle of something okay
now it's time to be the world's greatest
father husband
what's what do you do next after you set
that intention
well so first of all it's just about
having some you know something to aim
for
right it's like if if you
if i put a blindfold on you and i said
okay here's a dart evan
good luck you know try to hit a bullseye
like you wouldn't even know where the
dartboard was
right so it's like the chances of you
even getting cl
it's you're not even get close to the
dartboard i don't even tell you like
what wall it's on you know
but um even if you're like horrible at
darts
you're gonna get way closer just because
you had a target um
you know without the blindfold on so
first and foremost it's
it's that intentionality because think
about it like how how many people
actually
when they're about to cross through the
threshold of their home
do it with and i'm going to show up now
at my best for my spouse and my kids or
my partner or whatever
i wasn't doing that right before that i
would get home
you know to be brutally honest what
would happen so
kids would want to play and ah let me
finish this work
um you know maybe later you know my wife
might want to
you know talk or you know ask me for
some help on something i can't wait to
you know the weekend or something i'm a
little bit tired right now but
is that how the is that how the world's
best father responds is that how the
world's
best husband responds so
you know that the the intentionality
just it changes the way you show up
because you have something to measure
against
it doesn't make you perfect so it's like
you know you're trying to get the kids
to bed
or you get in that you know we all get
in arguments right with our significant
others
and that stuff still happens but then
it not only provides intentionality but
then it provides like counsel
like wise counsel in the moment because
there's been so many times where like
the argument
starts and old me is like ready to say
something back or something to
you know aggravate it and then i'm like
whoa world's best husband
you know how does he respond right now
it doesn't matter
everything that's just been said before
at any moment in time
there are always and only two choices
there's the best response that you could
give and there's everything else
and so you know so you get that wise
counsel in a moment and then number
three i love thinking in threes as you
can see
number three so you got the
intentionality before the moment right
you got the wise counsel
in the moment and then you know
sometimes you just crush it and you're
like yeah i really showed up
at my best in the gym today boom you're
like yeah that was awesome i was world
fitness champion or i was you know the
world's best husband whatever
but then there's other times when you
just totally screw up you didn't catch
yourself in the moment
and it's still powerful because you're
like
man i was totally not
the world's best father just then i was
totally not the world's best husband i
totally not the world's best coach i was
totally not
a world fitness ship i wasn't anywhere
close it's so beneficial in
all the scenarios because you can at
least
you have a gap you have data right you
have this is where i'm trying to get to
and this is where i landed and that's
that's a game changer really it is
you get a lot of love in the chat
there's a question here that i
think is interesting um eat lift
life is asking i need this book so does
my husband
always on the phone working all night so
i mean the book is out
again three alarms you can go check it
out have you
seen couples going through it and and i
mean i guess i'm sure you have and the
last section's all on relationships
would you would you recommend
going through the book together would
you recommend like you each read it
separately on your own and then discuss
like how do you use it as a relationship
book
if somebody wants to do this with their
spouse
i thought i would totally read it
together i don't think it needs to be
read separately
the book presents you some hard-hitting
truths right
so when you're reading it and if you
think your spouse you know
needs it it's going to be hard for them
to deny
kind of the words that they read because
it will definitely
it will definitely you know hit home um
i would read it together though
um you know my my wife has obviously
read it
so i hope
but yeah no i would just i would read it
together but um
here's the thing though with all this
kind of stuff it's
it's way more powerful if
you read it and you be the light
you know if there's like darkness in
your relationship
then just focus on being the light
because eventually
you know light wins at the end of the
day we all know that star wars right
um but but uh just just
i would just focus on you know be in the
being the exemplar
of the principles and then at some point
that will probably prompt the other
person to go
hey what the hell is going on here and
and you just keep saying i told you it's
that book that i read you know you
should take a read of it
is there an accountability piece to it
too like i'm sure
if you i mean your wife knows that at 6
30 you're trying to be the world's best
husband
and then if if something happens and
you're not you know
and you're sure oh yeah like hey world's
best husband
where are you eric come on now like is
that is that does that
help and the other remind because you
got the alarm on your phone but
but your wife then becomes the backup
alarm in case you kind of forgot the
real
the first alarm you got it and you know
what that's good
and if you're brave if you're courageous
you put your ass out on the line there
right and you say look
i'm gonna try to be the world's best and
and people will call you out on it
because they're like well you said you
do
you're all about this but you did that
you want that that's good
yeah there's um so you have you know you
have the alarms you have other people
who can call you out but then there's
like another
there's another thing that i do every
morning as part of this
and i call them champion proofs so the
way i think about it is that
if each of these identities if that's
like the champion version of you showing
up right in each of those
those arenas then what what can you do
on a daily basis to evidence that you're
showing up as your champion self
in each of those areas and so at the
start of the day independent of the
alarms going off i just say to myself
okay if i'm a world fitness champion in
the context of today
what am i doing let's you know it might
be a cardio day and i say i'm going to
hit 700 calories or something on the on
the stationary bike
um you know if it's world's best coach
what am i doing today and i i might say
i'm going to crank out a bunch of
youtube videos
you'll like that one right all right
channel it's going check it out eric
parker on youtube
um and um and then you know
i might say my number one you know my
champion proof
on the home front is i'm gonna write and
i love you note to
my wife or i'm gonna play video games
that's like such an easy one for me to
do so i'm going to play video games with
with my boys
you know um so have you you know you
you're creating some accountability for
yourself too by deciding what
what am i going to do in the context of
today
such that by doing it i evidence that
i'm stepping into me at my best
in each of these three areas and is that
something you're doing
every morning or that's like a weekly
thing that you look at and try
every morning every morning before you
go and be the world's best
best uh athlete you're also thinking
okay tonight when i get home this is how
i'm gonna be the world's best father and
husband
yeah i'm just picking one action just
one thing which if i did
so like if i do at least those three
things in the day no matter what happens
with the rest of the day
i'm like today was a win because i did
those three number ones in each area
and um and it can change right that's
the beauty of it so
world's you know best husband and father
it may mean one thing one day but
something else
completely on another day and then the
other thing too is like just to be clear
i those are the phrases i picked in each
of those areas
you you pick your own thing you know you
might say that when it comes time for
work like you turn into
elon musk i don't know or you know or um
and then
at you know sometimes in the evening i
thought of myself as mr rogers
because i thought that guy is like the
ultimate family guy you know
so so how do you how do you handle
the bleed of one into the other because
i think um
are you just timing and just like time
stamping it and say from this time to
this time because
often i think entrepreneurs all go
through this
there's a competing lives where
the world's best coach conflicts with
being the world's best husband because
you're in the middle of a coaching
session
but your wife really needs you to do
something but it's not
6 30 it's four o'clock and
how does how does like one eric fight
the other eric to
make the right choice yeah that's such a
good question
i mean this the last thing that this
should introduce in your life
is rigidity um you gotta stay flexible
and they they are like sign posts
for the segments of the day which are
primarily
driven by you know whatever that domain
is so in the morning
when before the day starts it's
primarily a health focus for me so it
makes sense to be driven by that
identity during the day it's primarily a
work focus during the evening it's
primarily a family focus
during the weekends that work alarm
doesn't even go off
right on saturday sunday but there's
always
you always know what the what the right
decision is so
you know if your husband or your wife
comes in
and it's like urgent or they're calling
you and it's it's clearly urgent
well there's a choice what is the best
thing the
best version of you the overarching best
version of you
you know what's the choice is is it that
you take the call is it that you leave
work you know
you you'll always know deep down you'll
know what the truly
you know the 95 year old version of you
the most wise version of you the best
version of you
what choice would they make what is the
right choice you'll know and if you just
ask yourself that question
you'll get the right answer and you know
even though
the world fitness champion for example
is the identity you know in the morning
for the gym
yeah i mean later in the day if i got
the choice between the donut or the
apple
that identity's still in mind and you
know it's like okay well
which one would the world fitness
champion choose
and this isn't like you know this this
is not
i try to i i try i always think of 80
as a good hit rate if if i can be making
choices that 80 percent of the time are
consistent
with the best of me that's a life well
lived
if you know if i make choices you know
as long as i'm not hurting
you know somebody but it's like if i you
know i have pizza or something
that's okay right as long as as long as
i'm going for that 80
hit rate i've actually started a new
thing too by the way which is quite cool
so
i have um i have a calendar up on my
wall and um
and i just it's like this overarching
thing so at the at the start of the day
i just have this intention
i'm just gonna try to do my best today
um that's that's my intention
and then and then it's it's the you know
best self
daily game i call it and i get to the
end of the day
and if i did my best in the context of
that day i give myself
a w if i didn't do my best in the
context of
of that day i give myself an l so a w
for win or an l for learn
and you're just on the calendar yeah i
just write a w
or an l and then they and the game is
simple it's like
eighty percent right so that that
translates to no more than six
l's in a month you know usually and um
and then the other rule is
never two l's in a row so if i have an
off day
totally fine that just makes the next
day a rebound day
um and that's a nice way to gamify it
too
i mean you're you're kind of
demonstrating right now that flexibility
in that
you know your your best father best
husband alarm goes off at 6 30
but we're doing this at seven o'clock
your time there you go
because this is on my calendar right
it's like eric i go live at two
let's do this i'd love to talk about the
three alarms but my show's at two
so now you gotta decide okay well do i
go do everything show for
a hundred percent and i went down so
what did i and what did i do in that
situation
so i went down um i was downstairs
uh with my wife it was like 6 15 i said
i said gee her name is giselle
i call her g so i said gee i got this
i got this thing with evan it's at seven
o'clock
so you know i gotta pop back up for that
and she's like ah okay yeah that's her
she's like well that's cool that's great
um but the world's best husband you know
what did i do i communicated right so
here's what's going on you know and she
actually knew from it
about it earlier in the week but i just
reminded her and everything rather than
you know just stay locked up in the
office and she doesn't even hear from me
until later right
yeah and every day that eric's coming
home and then doing night interviews and
everything else then that becomes
then that becomes a problem you are what
you consistently do like the 80
really i love it but maybe that is so
serene here in the live has a question
maybe that answers it
don't you at any point feel exhausted
trying to be the world's best and
everything obviously none of us
are perfect how do you balance getting
stressed on days
when you don't yeah so this is
definitely not about
perfection it's just about like making
progress
it relates back to um
so abraham maslow you know with his
hierarchy of needs he
he said that in his research that the
path to deepest fulfillment
is in realizing your full potential
right
and and showing up at your best so i
really believe that i really believe
that
if i show up at my best
not in a stressed way but just doing my
best you know doing your best doesn't
need to
be oh my gosh you must be exhausted
because you've done your best i mean
these these ideas are not necessarily
linked together
you know i don't get exhausted by not
you know um saying mean
things or you know being a jerk to
people or
you know it's like it's they don't
necessarily
relate so i think you know the person
asks i think
you can definitely separate those things
um you can be your best and still be
peaceful you can be your best and so be
calm you could be your best and
still not be stressed um yeah
so they don't they're not necessarily
linked together yeah
i still love the aim for 80 like don't
have perfection
standard i love it time flies when
you're having fun we've got to let eric
get back to being the best husband and
best father tonight
guys the book is called the free alarms
go check him out on instagram eric
partaker check out his youtube channel
too there's a lot of fire content there
and for my youtube audience we're going
to link it up down in the description
below to go check out the book
for one month you can get the free ebook
version as well or or
show eric's love yeah on amazon as well
eric
appreciate you man thanks for spending
some time with us tonight sharing your
wisdom
and i'm so pumped that the book is out
and it's been so successful
evan totally totally awesome thanks so
much man and thanks everyone who is
listening for the questions
love you all thank you much love if you
want to see the one on one i did with
tony robbins check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there the quality of your life has
nothing to do with how much money you
have how many beautiful children you
have how many people love you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool
it's a time for you to say where's the
world now where do i think it's going